uh wilma mccann a 28 year old mother of
four
was the first victim to be murdered by
sutcliffe in 1975 her son
richard mccann joins me now richard
thank you very much for being with us
on sky news this afternoon uh what went
through your mind
when you heard about this this morning
well first of all how i heard about it
this morning which was a relief was not
by
seeing it in the uh in the media it was
my little voice
mason ellis came to tell me said dad
he's died and his friend had told him
uh my initial thoughts were disbelief
because we had we had heard last year
that he had a heart attack was going to
die
never did so i checked and then
obviously it was confirmed and
mixed emotions not sure nobody prepares
you
for that surreal experience and but not
celebration
is is one thing i will say and that
might have been something i would have
felt as a young adult i'm 50 now i have
51 actually
matured and yeah i realized is anger
and revenge you know that's not good for
the soul so i i let go of that
10 years ago so strange emotions i went
up to tell my wife and i hugged my wife
and
and you know i weren't getting on i
actually picked up the phone
to kyle's upcliff his brother and sent
my commiserations uh
condolences uh carlos wrote to me many
years ago when he read my book about my
journey and and felt some compassion for
me so
you know as much as he did those
horrible things
he and i wasn't a cassock wasn't uh
sorry peter wasn't his greatest fan i'm
getting tongue tied
carl wasn't peter's greatest fan but he
still was his brother after all and i i
i felt like you owed him that compassion
what did he say to you
can i can i leave that private between
us and you know he just found out
himself so i'll kind of
you know um absolutely no no that's
absolutely fine of course
um what's it been like richard uh
growing up
knowing your chance of having a mother
was was taken from you
by a stranger
it's just it's just been the most
surreal thing ever and what was it like
i don't know it's like i've been born
into some kind of movie
it was just you know up until mum dying
i was just like everybody else and
and it's just been so surreal
that it was done in this public way and
i've never well for many years until
until about 15 years ago i
i was embarrassed about being associated
with suckling for these crimes
and then to some degree i was
embarrassed about my mum i was
embarrassed about the way that
she was described by you know some of
the media
but some of the police you know some
were innocent some were
less innocent and that had an impact on
me
and i felt shame i i felt shame for
um for and i'm glad you're sharing that
that more positive picture of mama
because the picture that was shown by
the police
sorry by the media but given by the
police was her police mug shot when she
was 18 and
she made a mistake shoplifting and i
hated that photograph because it wasn't
my
mum and every time i saw that picture
over the years
many many times it almost distanced me
from her so um
what i am celebrating if maybe not
celebrating but
what i'm grateful for is he's gone now
and with a bit of luck there was uh
sometimes really sensational stories and
a reminder of what he did
in the media i'm talking about the
tabloid in particular here
will decline and with a bit of luck and
we'll finish because they won't have
things to write about him now that he's
gone
it may well be uh the last day we we
speak of him
largely richard um
one thing that uh i've wondered is do
you think about
him every day is it something that that
you've thought about every day peter
sutcliffe or have you managed to
sort of push it out of your mind as you
get on with your your own life and have
your own family
it's a bit like the tide you know it
comes in and it goes out
but it's always there what i will say is
that there was times in my life as a
20 year old 30 or that i would
think about exactly how she died you
know
how much she had felt and that caused me
some distress over the years but
i don't have those feelings anymore my
mum's gone
his death doesn't bring her back and
you know but i have been there but
i should have been able to get on with
my life eventually i'm now married i've
got three wonderful children who
who keep us busy like everybody else i
am just like everybody else but
yes the thoughts of of of mum
and and him are just there it's almost
like it's in your cells of your body
because it's been
so public uh and like i said with a bit
of luck
we'll we'll start to see the end of that
let's hope so and
in the past you've talked about your
your sister who who tragically took her
own life how much of sutcliffe's actions
do you think were responsible for that
i i think they played a big part in in
in how she coped or or didn't cope in
fact you know it was
she was before mum dad she was the
almost like the second mum to us because
mum would sometimes leave us and sonia
would look after so when
when mum died she she took on that
responsibility and she cared for her
younger siblings
but there was other things that she
experienced in hell in her life which i
won't go into but personal things which
which affected her too and brought her
to drink so
i i i'm not going to give supply for
credit for
uh sonia uh taking her life but it
certainly influenced her
ability to cope with life but there was
other things involved as well
not many criminals get a title he was
given this title
yorkshire ripper it gave him notoriety
didn't it
which means obviously he was in the
headlines for many many years
after his arrest did you find that
frustrating
uh absolutely one of the things
in fact i was speaking to somebody
earlier one of the things that i love to
come from this is
is is for the media and it's quite easy
to do
and we heard fraser there just calling
the ripper
let's stop calling these these
perpetrators of these significant crimes
by these names that we give them
call them peter sutcliffe we know who it
is and
we've got to remember when you use those
descriptive words
the r word let's say it reminds us of
what took place so um
yes it caused me some frustration but it
also i believe has inspired
other killers who we've learned about
over the years
and to follow in their footsteps and
have been found to have books about
succliffe in in their belongings and
such like so
yeah that giving them that title is
something i'd see
and i would hope that we would we would
not make that same mistake and give them
that notoriety going forward
uh martin brunt made a point in his
report our our crime correspondents
saying that at the time
he divided opinion many believed he was
insane others that he was simply evil
what do you believe
it's a really difficult question to
answer
if i start imagining being evil
it takes me into that that that arena
of negative emotions and negative things
and thoughts i'd rather
believe that he was ill because then
that's more palatable shall we say uh so
so
i don't think says as clear cut as one
or the other but i would i'd rather
think about and
decide that it was ill rather than evil
although i have to say you know he did
some evil things
and of course we know the investigation
uh richard was was
was very flawed um and the police were
led down a number of um
blind alleys do you find that
frustrating that other people
have been put into a similar position as
you have lost loved ones which
may not necessarily needed to have
happened
yeah i mean it's been well documented
how
the the mistakes the many mistakes have
been interviewed nine times and the
the hoaxer and not listen we could talk
about that
until the cows come home um and i'm not
sure about anything
positive can come from pointing the
finger again
at that lessons were learned things came
about because of those mistakes like the
homes computer system where they joined
the dots together
in ways they weren't able to do
throughout his
his crimes so so i'm not sure we can get
anything but
what i will say and i've been saying it
for a couple of times this morning what
can come out of this a positive thing to
come out of this is um
and is is for west yorkshire police
to finally do the right thing and and
give us
another little bit of closure that we we
we can have and deserve
and that is to apologize for the way in
which they spoke about
some of the victims who including my mum
were less than innocent when j mcdonald
the 16 year old girl who we knew by the
way
was killed it was said by the police
that is killed an innocent victim now
my mum and all those other women were
completely innocent and deserved to live
and so so i would ask them to consider
uh my invitation to to make that apology
maybe
at this point in time or this
significant time and in the in the
at the end of this uh this journey we've
all been on
yeah and finally you uh mentioned that
you've spoken to sutcliffe's brother
have you spoken to any other relatives
today
uh i have i i have i i spoke to one and
we we
we reflected uh how it is for us and
and we are just like everybody else you
know i'm just like the man next door
we've been born into this life and it's
so surreal
and we had a good chat and we had a good
chat about what is going on in his world
so we're not consumed with focusing and
he certainly isn't celebrating either
um celebrating what's going on but i
appreciate that some people
will will be more than happy to see his
um his end